Một chiến năm mới Trung Quốc đã kích hoàn tơ trẻ vó khẩn cấp cấp bốn.
Sau khi sẽ giả trình động đất của độ lần 5 phải bốn tại về n tân lòng cho tự trị giến tổng tảng
căng tư tình tử suyên.
Thế chúng ta mạng lưới động đất Trung Quốc, trình động đất này sẽ giảm lắm người ba dần
mì bài phút theo dưới mắc kinh.
Tại vì chỉ có tỏa đồ băng người phẩy tảm đường đồng v mắc và chính phẩy tảm đồng kinh đồng.
Với đồ xấu tránh tiêu khoảng 1 kinh lưu mẹ,
nơi xò khi sự việc phẩy ra chính quyền tình tử suyên đã điều đọc lượng cứu hộ
ý tế và giáo thông đến khu bực tâm tránh để hỗ trận lý dân pháp phục hộ quả
và bảo đảm ắn tỏng cơ sửa hạ tần trọng yếu.
Trung Quốc hiện dưới chỉ có trị vó khẩn cấp bốn cấp.
Trong đó, cấp một là cấp nhất.
Để kinh hoàn tâm bốn cho phép chính quyền địa phương chủ đậm chín khai khu hộ
và báo cáo tình dình thử thải lên cấp chủ hương.